Our Father in Heaven once again we are
thankful that we can study together we
pray again Lord that your Holy Spirit
would be present to guide us to inspire
us Lord you're the one that gave this
gift of Prophecy now send the holy
spirit that inspired the prophets
to give us illumination and help us to
understand
more about this wonderful gift we ask
and pray it in Jesus name amen
had a question that came up during the
break so I'm going to kind of touch on
it just briefly
about future profits has anybody ever
wondered about that the gift of Prophecy
said we got Ellen White but the Bible
says in Joel 2 that there are going to
be prophets in the you know son of your
sons and daughters will have visions
your old mammal dream dreams your
you're familiar with that and so
sometimes people ask well in the last
days we feel that that uh prophecy of
Joel has to do with the last days are we
going to have are we going to see
manifestations of the gift of Prophecy
in the last days this is my short answer
first of all
um I believe that we are
but I don't know for sure
I believe that we are from that text but
I'll tell you something else Ellen
White's role as a prophet was different
you know some Bible prophets had
different roles than others Jeremiah
Ezekiel Isaiah
of course there we call them the Major
Prophets these guys were career Prophets
they spent much of their life they wrote
many testimonies there were other
prophets no less inspired but who
weren't as prominent who didn't have his
far-reaching a work you go to those New
Testament prophets how much do you hear
about agabus you know one little portion
in Acts 19 after besides that I think
there's another place in Acts 2. that's
it
the four daughters of Philip Acts
chapter 19 where else do you hear about
them where do you read about any of
their prophecies
it's not in there and so I believe just
in the early church had lots of prophets
I believe it that we will see the gift
of Prophecy restored
um in in a major way in fact well I'll
just say but at the same time I don't
believe that we're going to have another
career prophet
that has the same role as Ellen White
did now something you may not understand
or know of is that in the early Church
in the early Seventh-day Adventist
Church in the formation of our church
our young men and young women were
Dreaming Dreams and having visions did
you know that not just Ellen White
did you know that
James White had a vision when he was
going into an area once where the Lord
showed him Envision a situation that was
gonna that ended up he incurred he ran
into with the trying to preach the
message there with one of the local
ministers
um
in fact there's one place James White
went into a town to preach
I'm trying to remember the guy's name
it's a really neat story
and um
I can't remember his name right now
James White went into preach in a town
you know that in those days it wasn't go
to the church every Sabbath let's get on
your horse and ride and go find a place
and preach the message and go to another
and go and preach for a week or two and
do you know some meetings about the
Lord's coming and then you go somewhere
else
he went into a small town and there was
a gentleman in that town
who was the town infidel okay this guy
was not a religious guy didn't go to
church and the people in the town you
know in the in the early Advent message
when these guys were going around
preaching there was a religious revival
in the land so a lot of the people were
Christian
but this particular fellow was not a
Christian at all and the people said man
he came out to James White's meetings
they're like I don't understand he's
never come out to anything before
they said I I don't think you're going
to reach that guy because he's just you
know nobody's been able to get through
to him
so as the guy was out every night every
day every meeting James White had this
man was there at the meetings and as the
meetings concluded James White was on
his way out of town and he went and he
stopped by to visit with the man
and he asked him why he came out to the
meeting and the man said Elder White
before you came into town I had a dream
and in my dream I saw a man that looked
just like you he was dressed the same
way riding it on a horse and he said and
that man preached a message and he says
that message was stirring he says when I
went out to hear you the first night he
said you preached the message of the man
in my dream preached he says I knew the
Lord sent you okay this was this
happened often
okay the Lord still does this today
brothers and sisters where needed
you know have you ever said I wish the
Lord would just tell me something a
little bit more clear write it in the
clouds or something so you know you ever
want to clear a sign from God
I'm convinced that if I needed one God
would give it to me
and same with you
and so a lot of times we say well I wish
God would make it more plain
most of the time he has
it's usually not an issue of being plain
for us
um and I and I firmly believe that the
Lord will work in that way and I'll tell
you what when I pray for my family
members that are out of the faith and
when I pray for friends out of the faith
I say Lord you know I've seen you work
these Mighty miracles in the past
you know you change not and I know if
you need to Lord you'll do whatever it
takes and I just pray that he does
whatever it takes and it's encouraging
to me to see how he worked but let me
share with you a little story along the
same lines
this to me is one of the most stirring
stories that uh that I've read of the
early Advent movement
um there was a woman by the name of uh
let me get her Rebecca Smith
of West Wilton New Hampshire Rebecca
Smith had two children a daughter named
Annie and a son named
Uriah
neither of them were in the faith the
passing of time came in 1844 the great
disappointment they had been interested
in the coming of the Lord but they both
kind of gotten caught up into their
lives they were young going to college
having big plans for themselves
and this mother feared that her children
were drifting away and so she and Elder
Smith prayed a prayer for her children
and she wanted so desperately that they
would come back to the lord well Elder
Bates came to town to hold a meeting
and it says here that Elder Bates
visited West Wilton and before him Mr
Mrs Smith laid the case of her children
and their conversation was made a
subject of Prayer
Elder Bates was expecting in a few days
to hold meetings in Somerville
Massachusetts at the home of Paul Folsom
and Mrs Smith was to write to her
daughter inviting her to attend the
meeting
in the meantime Elder Bates
and the mother were to pray that God
would move upon the heart move upon her
heart to go to that meeting
Elder Bates had never been in the room
where the meeting was to be held and
therefore he who knew nothing of its
situation he didn't know how the room
looked didn't know how it was set up
the night before the meeting he dreamed
of being in the room
and that every seat was occupied except
for the one just by the door
he also dreamed that he changed his
subject
from that on which he intended to speak
and spoke on the sanctuary question
that they had sung the first hymn prayed
and sung the second hymn
and he had just opened his Bible and was
reading unto 2 300 days then shall the
sanctuary be cleansed pointing to the
figure of the sanctuary on the chart
when the door opened and a young lady
entered the room took her seat in the
vacant chair
he also dreamed that the person was
Annie R Smith and that she at once
became interested and embraced the truth
Elder Bates meeting was on the Sabbath
and as there was no school on that day
Annie said just to please my mother I'll
go
the night before the Sabbath the night
before that Sabbath she dreamed that she
went and was late
that on arriving
at the door the first hymn had been sung
prayer offered and they were just
concluding the second hymn
that as she entered
she observed that every chair was
occupied but the one where
by the door
nothing that none of this has happened
yet by the way
that a tall Noble Pleasant speaker was
pointing to a chart such as she had
never seen before and was repeating unto
2 300 days
then shall the sanctuary be cleansed
she dreamed that what he said greatly
interested her and that it was the truth
she started for the meeting in ample
time but missed the way
so failed to get there
until the singing of the last of the
second hymn
when she entered everything was exactly
as she had seen it in her dream and The
Identical man of her dreams was
repeating in the same manner the text
from Daniel 8 14. it struck conviction
to her heart at once Elder Bates had not
thought of his dream until she entered
the door and took her seat
he had prepared to talk on another
subject but his mind would rest on the
sanctuary question while he was
repeating the text his dream flashed
into his mind and silently he prayed for
help to speak to the hearts of his
hearers he had great freedom in
explaining the passing of time with
which Annie was familiar then he set
forth the truth of the third Angel's
message in the Sabbath as he closed the
meeting he stepped up to Annie and said
I believe this is Sister Smith's
daughter from West Wilton I never saw
you before but your countenance looks
familiar I dreamed of seeing you last
night
then Annie told her dream she changed
she left the meeting with feelings and
aspirations all changed having there and
then accepted the truth of the Sabbath
and it goes on to say that up to that
time neither of them remembered their
dreams
until that particular point in time
and so there's a fulfillment of the Joel
the prophecy of Joel and that type of
thing happened in many places God will
speak to people in visions and dreams
doesn't necessarily mean they have the
gift of Prophecy
but God will guide through that manner
anyway that's one of my favorite stories
that's so powerful to me because it just
again I think of that if God was willing
to work that way then he's willing to
work that way now if need be when you're
studying with these people in these
meetings and you're like Lord and you're
pouring out your heart to him and
praying for these Souls the Lord will
work in whatever means necessary
to win people to the truth if it's time
for them to come in
amen
amen that was a little diversion
um you know I wonder if I should do this
I probably should I'm going to share
this now too because we talked about it
before
uh as far as Ellen White being a test of
Fellowship
I'm afraid if I put it off I'm going to
forget about it so I'm going to share it
with you this is what it says in the
review and Herald of June I talked about
Ellen White being a test of fellowship
or somebody who joins The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church in the review and
Herald of June 13 1871
James White
pointed out
let me read what I have here this is
from the uh biography element biography
Volume 2 Page 320. James White has he
this isn't on the sheet by the way
James White as he wrote of the situation
a group of uh from the Missouri camp
meetings in 1871 that opposed Ellen
White and the Visions James White was
talking about this group and he pointed
out that Seventh-day Adventist quote
believe that the spirit of Prophecy is
rested on Mrs White and that she is
called to do a special work at this time
among this people
he pointed out they do not however make
belief in this work a test of Christian
Fellowship
but after men and women have had
evidence that the workers of God and
then join hands with those who fight
against it are people claim the right to
separate from such that they may enjoy
their sentiments in peace and quiet
so he says here
after they've had opportunity to test
this and if they're fighting against it
he says our members claim the right to
separate from such people
can you imagine worshiping with people
every week that don't believe you know
in in the spirit of proud you believe in
it and so you're wanting to talk with
this I get sick and tired of hearing
that Ellen White all the time
well if you believe in it you don't have
a problem with it
and so that's what James White said
there now Ellen White says in
testimonies for the church volume one
page 328
if the new Believers fight against the
visions of which they have no knowledge
if they carry their opposition so far as
to oppose that in which they have had no
experience
and feel annoyed when those who believe
that the Visions are of God speak of
them in the meeting
and comfort themselves with the
instruction given through vision the
church may know that they are not right
God's people should not cringe and yield
and give up their Liberty to such
disaffected ones in other words God's
people should not give up their Liberty
to be able to speak of the Visions in
church
if people are in there being
or in our meetings we in other words we
shouldn't be embarrassed and have to say
oh we can't talk about Ellen White
she says if if people feel annoyed when
you when they somebody when they're
speaking about the Visions they're
evidently not in this let me give you
the setting again
this is after they've had a little bit
of opportunity or no this one here says
when they when they've had no knowledge
why would a person fight against
something they have no knowledge of
yeah you have
yeah you can I'll copy it for you
God had then she finishes up God has
placed the gifts in the church that the
church may be benefited by them and when
professed Believers in truth oppose
these gifts and fight against the
Visions souls are in danger through
their influence and it is time then to
labor with them that the weak may not be
led astray by their influence
so that's what I was commenting on
before there you have a little reference
for it
now
let's go back to the tests of the gifts
of Prophecy I'm not going to go through
we kind of touched on this and the
things that I read before all these
physical phenomena you can look through
that you have the references there to
kind of go through some of these
different things all the items there
number one two three four Etc come from
those passages you see above numbers 24
2-4 Daniel 10 10 7-9 15-18 second
Corinthians 12 2-4 that will flesh out
these physical characteristics but what
we're going to do is we're going to jump
ahead to the scriptural tests for the
prophetic gift was their hand
okay I thought I saw a hand all right
section c 10 scriptural tests for the
prophetic gift number one First
Corinthians 14 22 who would look that up
for me
and read it first Corinthians 14 22.
yes ma'am and again your name
Genie thank you Genie First Corinthians
14 and verse 22.
okay
what am I looking at there that's not
what I wanted
that's text that I have
oh no pardon me that is exactly what I
wanted brain lapse
First Corinthians 14 22 says tongues are
for who
unbelievers but prophecy is for
believers now what happens sometimes is
I remember I used to read that and I say
wait a minute then why do we have
prophecy meetings for unbelievers
right but that's not what it's talking
about it's talking more about
prophesying in other words when Ellen
White gives counsel like testimonies for
the church that's not primarily for
unbelievers
but for the church the testimonies if
you read them right there on the volume
says testimonies for the church right
notice what it doesn't say it doesn't
say testimonies against the church
right so when you're reading that and it
cuts kind of close just remember it's
still for the church testimonies for the
church the gift of Prophecy
is something that God gave for the
church test number one the prophet must
be associated with God's true church you
have people say hey have you read
Nostradamus man he's got some awesome
prophecies well he fails that first test
right off
Gene Dixon doesn't pass the test
a prophet is to guide the church we've
already looked at several of those
aspects of the the role of the gift of
Prophecy God gave the prophetic gift for
his church to guide his church
a prophet must be associated with God's
Church
you follow that you have questions on
that
notice some of the statements here I
just what I'm going to do is with each
one of these tests I've got a statement
from Ellen White
not by any means exhaustive but at least
to give a little bit from her writings
that so we can test the profit does
Ellen White fit this test well it seems
kind of obvious I want you to know what
note what it says there in that first
quote
if the idea is presented in this book
The Living Temple were received they
would lead to the uprooting of the whole
construction of the faith that makes
what
Seventh-day Adventist a Chosen One
denominated people what does denominated
mean
oh
that's right
denominated named named
god named this movement people say I
don't think we should ever become a
denomination we are a movement God
denominated us with the name Seventh Day
Adventist
that's what she says in another place
but here she says
um talks about you know the setting the
context of this is not really what we're
looking at so much as the fact that
Ellen White
Associates herself here with the
Seventh-day Adventist as God's chosen
denominated people he chose them pulled
him Drew us out from the world and gave
us a name
look at the next section there the next
quote
from special testimonies B page eight
we stand before the world and I wanted
to conclude that first paragraph to give
us the setting who's we Seventh-day
Adventist we stand before the world as
gods
denominated people he gave us the name
he pulled us out from among the world he
called us out with the Three Angels
messages come out of Babylon come into
His Remnant movement and he named us
Seventh-day Adventist we stand before
the world we she includes herself as
God's denominated people and we must do
our appointed work test number one does
she pass it yes she does God's prophets
must be associated with his church
test number two
First Corinthians 14 we're there verses
32 and 33 this is a this is an awesome
text 32 and 33 who wants to read that
First Corinthians 14.
let's get somebody who hasn't read uh
Joshua all right
and the spirit of the prophets are
subject to the prophets for God is not
the author of confusion but of Peace
okay the spirits of the prophets are
what
subject to the prophets what does that
mean
foreign
okay previous writings what happens if I
come along and I say hey I'm the newest
prophet and I've got some information it
doesn't exactly Accord with what's in
the Bible but that's old and I'm new and
therefore I'm the later revelation of
Truth
that doesn't fit this test does it it
says the spirits of the prophets are
subject to the prophets in other words
if somebody Rises up claiming to have
the prophetic gift
they've got to be in accord with what
all the prophets who went before them
have said
you follow that
it has to fit
it has to fit with what's gone before if
it doesn't
Joseph Smith
that's what that's what the Mormons do
with Joseph Smith you know that he's a
newer Prophet yes the Bible is true but
the Book of Mormon is truer because it's
later
it's newer it's more recent no the
spirit of the Prophet has to be subject
to the prophets now follow me for a
minute
if a prophet rose up
that was a true prophet and said well I
know the Bible says this but I say this
if that was possible to happen what
would that do to the church
what would it create
confusion
God is not the author of confusion
that's the point here God is not the
author of confusion how confusing it
would be if God could say well every
Prophet that comes up you know you the
one Prophet says a one Prophet says be
and then one Prophet says see and you're
like man what in the world do I believe
it would create confusion in the church
but God's not the author of confusion
he's the author of Peace the spirit of
the prophets are subject to the prophets
if a prophet comes claiming anything
they will give no
new
what I want to say
no additional truth
okay
now follow this I'll get your hand in a
minute it doesn't mean there won't be
new information
but it's not going to be new truth
that isn't in the Bible for example
I mentioned the other day here's Daniel
living in the day of Jeremiah Jeremiah
the prophet comes and he speaks this
prophecies that he does is everything
that Jeremiah wrote already in the Bible
no when Jeremiah came he had new truth a
new new
information but he didn't have new truth
he didn't say well there was this but
now there's this too
what Jeremiah said incidentally if you
were living in Daniel's day and a man
came up Rose up like Jeremiah said I've
got the gift of Prophecy how would you
know
how would you know if he had the gift of
Prophecy or not
oh come on
okay
I don't want a specific answer I want a
more General answer how would you know
what's that
how
you had to
test the profits that's what I was
looking for I was fishing for something
there I just wasn't getting it you have
to test the profits
Jeremiah had to be tested in his day
didn't he he wasn't in the Bible
Daniel didn't just say okay he says he's
a prophet I guess I'll believe him
because there were false prophets in
those days too you remember Jeremiah
dealt with the false prophets in his day
in fact there were a lot of false
prophets that went around they said oh
King babylon's not going to come and
take us captive God's going to deliver
them into our hands
so Jeremiah had to be tested what was he
tested by
the other prophets
the spirit of the Prophet had to be
subject to the prophets Jeremiah's
writings were subject to the other
prophets what about when the Apostle
Paul came and began preaching
did Paul give any new truth
are you sure
if you read Paul's writings carefully
you will see that Paul repeatedly says
that he is making manifest that which
has been written through the apostles
and Prophets
there was no new truth through the
Apostle Paul but there was additional
information
see the truth of God is so God keeps
bringing it out it keeps we we can see
more and more of it but it's not adding
to the truth
but there may be more information that
comes through the profit we see the same
thing in Ellen White Ellen White gives
us details on things that we don't see
in the Bible
but that doesn't make her a non-profit
now she comes in and says now I've got
additional truth it's not in the Bible
that I'm going to give you that
contradicts something in the Bible you
know
it's a false prophet Spirit of the
Prophet is subject to the prophets does
that make sense
yes
it just it basically means the uh in the
context it just basically means the uh
I'm looking for a good word for it
I in one sense I guess I would say the
spirit that inspired the prophet has to
be subject to the spirit that inspired
the other prophets
because he says in for in first John 4 1
Test the what
test the spirits
okay
and ultimately I think he's just telling
us there in First Corinthians that
whatever the spirit the proud that
Prophet is speaking from needs to be
tested with the
Spirit to the others speak of as well
it could mean spirit in the sense of
um their understanding
but the bottom line is that their
message the other all that's saying is
the message of that Prophet needs to be
in accordance with the message of the
other prophets
you follow that does that make sense
is everybody with us on that all right
the spirit of the Prophet must be
subject to the prophets they will not
contradict revealed truth if God has
revealed something the prophet a person
who claims to be a prophet is not going
to come and contradict it and change
everything around and so now you throw
out the old and bring in the new
Ezekiel 22 verse 28.
let's look at that one briefly this is a
contrast
Ezekiel 22
and verse 28.
who would like to read that for me
Ezekiel
um
you already read Ezekiel I'm trying to
get
Christine that's right Christine Ezekiel
and verse 28.
thus thank the Lord God when the Lord
hath not spoken okay speaking of the
false prophets the false Visions it says
the false prophet does what
line he lies
he said he what
you know the least you could do is just
read off the sheet that I gave you
prophets misinterpret the Bible
misinterpret the Bible
he says the Lord God has spoken when he
hasn't spoken
isn't that what it says
the prophet the false prophets say thus
say the saith the Lord when the Lord
hasn't spoken
so they're misrepresenting they're
misquoting
okay that that's a contrast the true
Prophet will never say something that
God hasn't said will never claim to it
you know say that this is true when God
hasn't stated it as being truth
a true Prophet must be tested by that
which the prophets have already written
and must be in accordance with it
you follow
okay next test
they magnify the law of God Isaiah 8 20
I'm not going to look that up I think
you know that if not you have the
reference there to the law into the what
testimony if it's not according to this
word there is no light in them
to the law into the testimony now we
could say in one sense the law and the
testimony what's the testimony
the prophets the spirit of Prophecy the
law and the prophets you find this
throughout we're going to see more of
this as we we have a study coming up
that we're going to
look at this link between the law and
the prophets
and law in in some cases
in the Old Testament in fact in a lot of
cases that were law you know what the
word pentateuch means you know what the
pentateuch is right
it's the first five books of the Bible
you know what the pennant took me you
know what Panda took means the law
it's a law is it defined it's the five
books it's called they call it the two
Torah means law thank you it's the and
so to the Jewish mind the law was the
five books of Moses but keep in mind
that the heart of the heart of the Books
of Moses was the Ten Commandment law of
God and
a prophet has got to magnify if a
prophet if a person claims to have the
gift of Prophecy and they're telling you
the law of God isn't important anymore
that was easy
right
to the law and the prophets and we go to
the New Testament Matthew 5 19 and 20.
let's look at that one Matthew 5 19 who
wants to read that
Craig
Matthew 5 19.
and 20.
sorry
Commandments
for I say unto you that accept your
righteousness shall exceed the
righteousness of the scribes and
Pharisees ye shall in no case enter into
the kingdom of heaven
all right so Jesus made it very clear
there in the New Testament that if
anybody comes in and and they make light
of the least of The Commandments of God
they will be least in the kingdom of
heaven and that means they'll be
regarded as least by those in the
Kingdom of Heaven I remember Doug
Batchelor once was talking about this he
says that doesn't mean they're going to
be in like some people think well you
know maybe you're in heaven but you'll
be driving a pinto when everybody else
is driving a Cadillac or something I
don't know if you guys even know what a
pinto is anymore do you and you guys
know what a pinto is some of you do
I used to drive a pinto
that was a mean machine now but
but that's that what Jesus is saying is
if somebody if somebody
teaches men that the law is unimportant
he says they're not even going to be
there they'll be thought of as least in
the Kingdom of Heaven
a true Prophet will magnify
the law of God
uh and I didn't read that last statement
let's look at it under under number two
in regarding the revealed truth
the prophet speaking in accordance with
the Bible notice what Ellen White said
in selected messages volume 3 page 29 I
recommend to you dear reader the word of
God as what
the rule of your faith and practice you
are not going to find something like
that written by Joseph Smith
you're not going to find that by Charles
Taze Russell
Jehovah Witnesses you will not find that
there but you will find you're not going
to find it by Nostradamus or Gene Dixon
either but Ellen White said the Bible is
the rule of your faith in practice by
that word we are to be judged
God has in that word promised to give
Visions in the last days not for a new
rule of faith but for the comfort of his
people and to correct Those Who air from
Bible truths it's always the role of the
Prophet Mr bring them back to the Bible
truth but the Bible was always the
standard okay
and magnifying the law of God
Ellen White says in testimonies for the
church volume six testimonies what
for the church
volume 6 page 3 95 it is our work to
magnify and exalt what
the law of God the truth of God's holy
word is to be made manifest we are to
hold up the scriptures as the what
the rule of life in all modesty in the
spirit of Grace and in the love of God
we are to point men to the fact that the
Lord God is creator of the heavens and
earth and the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the Lord
did this Prophet uphold the law of God
yes she did look at this next statement
I love this one starts on the top of
Page Three great controversy page 472.
quoting from the prophet John she's
subject to the prophets here
he that saith I know him and keepeth not
his Commandments is a liar and the truth
is not in him but whoso keepeth his word
in him verily is the love of God
perfected here is the test of every
man's profession
if men feel no weight of the moral law
if they belittle and make light of God's
precepts if they break one of the least
of these Commandments and teach men so
they shall be of no esteem in the sight
of heaven and we may know that their
claims are without Foundation
she speaks that of herself she puts
herself right in with anybody else hey
if I'm not meeting up to this criteria
she says you know my claims are false
she passes that test let's go to the
next one a true Prophet will acknowledge
the Incarnation of Christ first John 4 2
and 3 let's go there first John 4 2 and
3.
first John 4 2 and 3.
who wants to read this one for me we
read verse one it's just a continuation
one talks about testing the spirits
verses two and three yes ma'am Autumn if
you would read first John 4 2 and 3.
God
and every spirit that does not confess
that Jesus Christ is not of God and this
is the spirit of the Antichrist which
you have heard was coming and is
okay here's a test every spirit that
does not confess that Jesus Christ has
come in the flesh is not of God now how
many of you have you guys got into your
any little debates yet on the nature of
Christ
let me tell you something this morning I
want to tell you something that that
this
you know the devil the devil knows how
to pull the rug out from under us all
the time it just it's amazing to me I
want to tell you something about the
nature of Christ
the Bible says in first Timothy chapter
3 and verse 16.
it starts out with these two words
without
controversy
what does that mean what's controversy
argument without argument Paul says
in other words what he's about to tell
us he says there's no argument on this
point what I'm about to tell you you
can't argue it it's profound there's no
argument against it what I'm going to
say is absolutely 100 True without
controversy great is the mystery of
godliness
for God was manifested in the flesh
justified in the spirit and you go on
with the you familiar with the passage
God manifests in humanity Divinity and
Humanity combined Paul says there's no
argument on this this is the greatest
mystery that we could fathom
and we've got all these Adventists
saying got it
I've got that one figured out
I got the nature of Christ right now
that's the nature of Christ brothers and
sisters
Paul tells us that this is a mystery
that is the greatest of mysteries Ellen
White tells us it will be the science
and song as a redeemed through Eternal
ages and we've got people who want to
debate that you've got to see it my way
or your way right now because I've got
it figured out
does that make sense
does that make sense to say now aren't
there other things that we can know
about that we can know a lot more about
we pick the things that God says are the
greatest Mysteries and say I'm going to
debate and argue this point right now
that seems a little odd to me now we're
going to talk I'm going to talk a little
bit about this as we look at applying
some of Ellen White's writings on the
issue of the nature of Christ
notice I didn't give you any any answer
as to where I stand on that
but I did tell you that I think it's
foolish to sit and debate it I've
watched people that ought to be giving
the Three Angels messages waste their
time debating the nature of Christ and I
don't know what heaven thinks about it
but I just can't I I don't feel that
that impressive that that heaven is
really smiling on that while souls are
being lost because we're trying to get
their bearings on this issue
you follow that
boy you guys are quiet on that one
yeah yeah
I I understand that I understand that
yes
I'm not even saying it's not a subject
that doesn't demand attention but I'm
saying I could go on to say that to
debate anything the way some things are
debated in our church today the spirit
of debate is contrary to the to the
character of Christ
that doesn't mean we shouldn't stand for
things but I mean it just but we'll get
into that more but here's something that
we need to understand very clearly this
test there are there are those who do
not believe that Christ took upon
himself real Humanity now I know that
people in the nature of Christ issue as
a whole those that I understand even
with the pre-fall post fall nature
believe that Christ took
Human Nature but not everybody believes
that
some people believe that Christ doesn't
didn't take that Christ was immune from
Humanity
all together that it was all just kind
of a make-believe thing
and that's why I put this quote in here
notice what Ellen White says in
reviewing Herald April 5.
Christ did not make believe take human
nature
he did verily take it
he did in reality possess human nature
as the children are partakers of Flesh
and Blood he also himself likewise took
part of the same
he was the son of Mary he was of the
seat of David according to human descent
he is declared to be a man even the man
Christ Jesus Jesus Christ took upon
himself humanity and we are told in the
spirit of Prophecy that he will bear
Humanity for eternity
by choice
Jesus is in a glorified body yet it's a
glorified human body
and I believe that Christ lost some of
his prerogatives some people argue this
too but I can't see how Christ could
take human nature and not lose some
aspect of divinity
and to me that is the essence of the
sacrifice he made for us
you and I don't know what it's like to
lay aside divinity
I mean we don't know what it's like to
leave the Palaces of Heaven
did you know Ellen White says that
Lucifer
as he
I believe this is in the Temptation
chapter of Desire of Ages as Lucifer
studied
the sanctuary service
the sacrifices
and read into that what it was telling
him that Christ was going to die a
sacrifice for Humanity
she said he could not fathom
the kind of love it would take for God
to do
what he was doing if it said the devil
knew what heaven was like and the devil
she says he looks at Humanity Humanity
has no concept of what heaven's like you
know
I mean
he knew what Christ left behind in
heaven and she said the devil had no he
could he could not fathom
the kind of love that it would take for
Christ to leave behind what was in
heaven to come down and take human
nature upon himself
and incidentally his intellect is
greater than ours did you know that
there's a statement I read where Ellen
White says this uh she talks about
intellect you know sometimes we we give
a lot of credibility to intellect a man
has a lot of degrees a lot of initials
after his name and everything else says
this she says if we owe if if intellect
was what demanded our our worship if
intellectual and wisdom and mental
prowess was what
um
what demanded our worship she said then
our homage would be due to Satan because
his intellect far exceeds any human
beings and electives ever exist that's
ever lived
and he couldn't fathom it
are you with me
what we're clear on is that Christ took
upon himself our Humanity
we'll talk a little bit more about that
Stephen Wallace spent a lot of time on
that
but there are those who do not claim
that Christ took upon himself our
Humanity
does Ellen White Pass that test
you just read it right there she made it
very clear this no Christ didn't make
believe take human nature there wasn't
some trick done with mirrors
he in reality took upon himself our
Humanity
are you with me so far yeah
got something in my throat
okay
next
their profit their their prophecies must
come true